Bring on a pandemic. I got cash. That's
how I went broke.
Walk me through how you ended up scaling
that. If you had advice that you could
give 40-year-old Dave, what would you
tell him?
I am super thrilled to be here today
because
uh Dave's a legend. And uh I'm going to
I'm going to give a little bit of an
intro from my perspective um of you.
This is a little scary.
Um and I and I actually wanted to take
the first like few minutes to um
actually just kind of like hype Dave.
And I think it's because like in the
marketplace of attention right now, I
actually still think you're underpriced.
Um I still think that you are
underappreciated for the amount of value
that you provide to the audience at
large.
And flattery will get you everywhere.
Got me here.
But one of the things I wanted to hit on
was um like I see and I'm sure you do or
your team does, like there are a lot of
people who take I would you know I'll
use the term figure, but a lot of people
who
haven't achieved, you know, a 100th of
the level of success that you have that
take a lot of shots and at you and you
know, a lot of specifically around your
views on debt, but sometimes just in
general. And um
you know, we have a big belief at at
acquisition.com that the only people
ever hate you um are never ahead of you.
Uh and I feel like that's been extremely
true and been tough for people to be
ahead of you in general.
Um but I just want to give context for
my audience
that number one uh
you've been doing this for three
decades?
Yeah, a little over. Yeah.
Three decades
uh and your overnight uh three decade
success.
Yeah, for real.
And
Just just in time to get old.
I what I'm going to be directing the the
conversation today around is actually
around business stuff. So, Dave has a
zillion things on personal finance. I
mean, I think that was the you know, the
the wedge product that a lot of a lot of
everything.
But because our audience is
predominantly business owners, I want to
focus on the actual building of Ramsey
Solutions and kind of some of the things
that you that you learned along the way,
some of the big mistakes that you did,
some things that you'd go back in time
and would have done differently.
And even as you've kind of scaled the
brand. So that's kind of the direction.
Does that work?
Okay. So um
can you give a little bit of background
in terms of how
Ramsey Solutions the education business,
which was the first business, correct?
They've all kind of evolved together.
Okay.
Um
how did that come to be? And then what
was your thinking around the business
model at that time?
And like what has it evolved into?
Well, um
all of it started
extremely
primitive.
I mean like 1 + 1 equals
two barely, you know, kind of thing. And
so like for instance, we started a
I went down there's a talk radio show or
talk radio station in Nashville at the
time that was in Chapter 11 bankruptcy.
And there was a guy doing a bad
financial show, like a Saturday Night
Live skit, you know, on there. I went on
as a guest on the bad financial show.
And I didn't have any books. I just went
on for fun. I was actually promoting a
real estate club I was in. And
he said, "Hey, I hear you're helping
people with your with foreclosures and
helping them stop getting the car repoed
or if they're having financial trouble
over at your church. Are you doing
that?" And I said, "Yeah, I'm just kind
of doing that for fun just to help folk
at as a ministry at the church." And he
goes, "Well, if you got any questions
about that, call up." And phone rang and
he never got any phone calls. He didn't
know what to do. He didn't even know how
to put the guy on the air. And so
he said, "Hey, come back. Let's do that
again cuz his phone never rings." And so
I went I did it like two times and then
he quit. And then we went down talked to
that guy that that was running that
station into letting us work for free.
And so, a couple guys, me and a couple
other guys went on the air uh answering
questions uh
um in a really heavy hillbilly twang.
Uh
WW T N
you're talking Niceville. Y'all call in.
I mean, it was it was nasty, buddy. I'm
telling you it was nasty. And uh but
with information was good and the phone
rang
Yeah.
from the very first day. A- A- About the
same time I had finished writing uh on
my laptop in my living room
uh
on the very first version of Windows.
This is 1992. Uh my first book. And uh I
self-published it, carried it home in
the trunk of my car, got 1,000 copies.
And I went on the radio and said, "Hey,
y'all get my book." And um some people
did.
And uh and the
18 months later educat- to get to your
question
Yeah.
we moved the uh card table out of my
living room and one old beat-up desk
from the days when I went bankrupt and
opened an office in an 800-sq-ft
month-to-month rent. And me and another
guy, another guy was going to do
financial coaching the way I teach to do
that. I was going to continue to do
that. And we launched a in April of 1994
a class on how to handle money. It was
actually how to avoid bankruptcy.
Um and one of the lessons was on the
different types of bankruptcy. One of
the lessons was on how to stop a
foreclosure if it's an FHA, if it's a
VA, or if it's Fannie Mae, different
processes to stop a foreclosure. Um and
you know, all these different thing. And
the people that came weren't bankrupt.
They were just making a lot of money and
spending it all.
Oh, okay.
So, they were broke. It was all the
money comes in, all the money goes out,
only the names are changed to protect
the innocent, but they weren't
behind on their house payment.
Right.
They just were fighting with each other
in their marriage, and they didn't know
how to do a budget, and no one ever told
them about insurance. So, I took the
bankruptcy and the foreclosure lesson
out and replaced it with a
uh
uh retirement lesson and a here's how
investments work lesson. Uh compound
interest, woo, and which is, you know,
still for the general public causes
their
uh brains to to just go melt down in in
a wonderful way the first time you see
compound interest, right? And so, yeah,
we that was called life after debt
um
in April.
And uh four people came the first night.
I sold three of them.
So, for you digital people, I had a 75%
conversion rate set up, right?
But, um I'm telling you it was
primitive. Overhead projector, bad suit,
you know, that whole thing. And then we
changed it to go to called it Financial
Peace University the
5 months later in September, 6 months
later.
And now Financial Peace University's had
10 million people go through it
and 50,000 churches have taught it.
Unbelievable.
So, for
context, the services that you had was
education with some level of service
kind of like holding accountable or
keeping them consistent on top of that.
Which the reason that I I was really
intent on talking to you was that in the
space that we're in today, and obviously
the the marketplace has changed a lot.
Mhm.
You have an education business.
And I would say that the vast majority
of quote education businesses are
not perceived as legitimate.
Mhm.
How do you think you've been able to
anchor in it like it's it's very clear
that Ramsey Solutions is a legitimate
business, obviously. Um but what do you
Why do you think that so many of them
are not
perceived that way?
Um
What's the gap? What are what are people
missing there?
I I honestly don't know. I I know that
um
in the financial world in general,
um and I think most of your listeners
and you and I will agree to this that
that
there's a lot of us I grew up in that
world and and and I'm a nerd by nature
and got a degree in finance for God's
sake, and so
I In other words, I thought the way to
to everything was with the math.
Mhm.
And math treats the symptom
Right.
not the problem. And what our brand
differentiator
and it may be the difference in what
you're talking about as well is that we
did come to understand that it's a
behavior problem. It's personal finances
80% behavior, 20% head knowledge. I've
said that like I don't know 8 million
times in 30 years.
And um but it is. And the problem with
my money is the guy in my mirror. If I
can get him to behave, he can be skinny
and rich. And we've talked about this
all these lines. These riffs that we do.
And we do them over and over and over
and over and over again. And but it but
but that's the differentiator. That's
the thing that said, oh, yeah.
Because I mean knowing how to do a
budget is different than actually doing
one.
Knowing how to live on less than you
make or that you should is different
than actually doing it. Knowing that
eating 73 donuts will make me fat is
different than not eating 73 donuts,
right?
Yeah.
Personal testimony. But the um but yeah,
that that stuff I think that's the
difference. And then what has happened
is
that if you go through and you do the
stuff that we teach
and we've got the systems in place to
help you be
held accountable to do it and encourage
you when you're struggling and scared
and hopeless
um but if you're arrogant and prideful,
either way we're going to be there in
your grill
saying we love you so much that you need
to change. If you do the stuff and you
actually make the changes due to the
accountability that that you that cuz
you keep doing what you've been doing,
you're going to keep getting what you've
been getting. So you got to change the
recipe. So if you change the recipe, you
have success. And lives transformed
is legitimacy. That gives you
legitimacy. And so in in other words, I
don't know if they set out to be
illegitimate.
Mhm.
But they didn't maybe they didn't have
the
uh the the the life wasn't actually
changed.
Mhm.
You know, if I join a gym
Yeah.
and then I don't get anything out of
that.
Yeah.
I don't have any weight loss, no
increased muscle tone, no um
you know, increased aerobic, whatever
whatever it is you're trying to
accomplish. If I don't get any of that,
even if it's my fault,
Yeah.
it feels like the gym is illegitimate. I
don't think the gym's necessarily
illegitimate, but the results were
illegitimate. And so then you get
labeled that way.
Yeah.
And so I hear people say Dave Ramsey
stuff doesn't work. The haters, right?
I know.
And
it absolutely does not work unless you
work it.
Yeah.
Like I guarantee that.
I can make you that personal guarantee.
Shifting back to the business,
um
explain to me how how the actual
products we developed over time. So in
the beginning you had the education and
then you had the services that that
layered on top of that.
Was that the main thing for like a
decade or and and like walk me through
how you ended up scaling that. Was that
all through media? Um we had the the
yeah.
Okay. The the radio show didn't make
money for a decade.
Mhm.
Um because I don't pay you to do radio.
Uh even today I don't get paid by radio
stations. I have a a clock split with
them. And so um and we didn't have
anything to sell when we split the clock
and so we didn't make any money. So
whatever we put in the radio was lost
dollars.
Um but it was the megaphone. It was the
uh the the the lead mechanism.
Mhm.
Uh okay. And so we we I started doing
some speaking and then I thought, "Hey,
we could do like a little public event
in town because we were on only on the
air in one town. But we so we went on
the radio and announced and I think we
had um I don't know 100 people or
something come out and
um paid us like 40 bucks or something to
sit for 3 hours or 5 hours or whatever
it was and listen to me yammer in my
hillbilly twang about getting out of
debt. And so we had the live events
started to develop. Uh we had the little
book, so we had a little bit of a
publishing thing going. And we had the
class itself, uh which was a long form,
uh it's a combination of 12 step and
curriculum, so to speak. Um
and and and so radio, publishing, live
events, those were the first and what
becomes Financial Peace University were
the first element Oh, and one-on-one
coaching. One-on-one counseling, we
called it in those days. We now call it
financial coaching.
Um
so there's no confusion that we're not
licensed therapists. Um cuz some people
can't seem to It's not clear, but
anyway, coaching is hard to mess that
up. So, um yeah, so we do that, and each
of those things grew at different rates.
And so, there were different times in
the 30 years that
um
Financial Peace University was bringing
in the lion's share of the money. And
then publishing would come up and pass
it.
Mhm.
Uh live events has pretty much always
been a slightly profitable,
but really good secondary lead source.
Okay.
So, if you come to a live event, um
because you heard us on the radio, it's
going down the funnel, the marketing
funnel, so to speak. And then they might
buy Financial Peace University, which
is, you know, a
9-week commitment, and a high, you know,
instead of a $20 event ticket, it's a
$80 to go through it, or whatever like.
So, we were working that that and there
were always books on the back table,
too. So,
uh and so, once those things worked and
the book and we had a New York Times,
you know, the book eventually evolved
and was purchased by publisher and
became our first New York Times
bestseller. Um
once that happened, and then we start
doing a bunch of we start getting more
and more radio stations and doing more
and more media. So, instead of just
doing the little local news guy, we
actually, with the book tour for the
first time, got on the Today show. And
uh and then that opened up something,
then that opened up something, and then
pretty much been doing New York media
for 25 years.
Um obviously, all that's free, but it's
lead generation.
And so, if I were to say this back to
you, the radio station served as the big
megaphone to gather attention and then
point it in a direction. And one of the
places you'd point it in the earlier
days was the live events, which
functioned a little bit as a conversion
event for you guys from a business
perspective. And then those people would
get funneled into whatever was
appropriate for their budget, uh you
know, either they'd buy some books or
they'd buy the curriculum or they'd buy
the curriculum and some one-on-one
counsel
or
one-on-one financial coaching. Um and
then that machine has been what you've
continued to spin the wheel on and then
gather more and more and more media and
then
and we've got more and more product mix
now. I mean, we've got uh
you know, we ended up uh I advertised
for a stock brokerage firm. Um and then
when I sent the leads, the people would
go over there, the
local broker that they went to would
tell them to do stuff that I had just
told them on the air not to do.
And so, that didn't work. And um people
are pissed off. And
uh
yeah, and so, we said, "Well, guys,
y'all can't do that with the leads we
send you." "Well, you can't tell us what
to do." And I said,
"I can tell you you can't advertise, so
we're not going to be on the air." So,
we dropped those folk.
And um
so, the product suite from there, that
was the core initial product mix.
And then what we did was uh we would
hear about some need that was a a
similar thing, but a finger off of that.
So, for instance, a local coach at a
Catholic high school was took my
Financial Peace book and started
teaching his seniors cuz they needed to
know about personal finance.
With and then called me up and goes,
"Hey, I hope you don't mind." I'm like,
"Well, I
don't mind and I'm kind of complicated,
but let's work together on this. Let me
help." So, I went over and spoke to him
a couple times. They're sweet kids and
he's a great guy, too. Greg Carson, he's
a friend of this day. That was And we
ended up out of that developing a high
school curriculum. This has now been
taught in 48% of the high schools. 6 and
1/2 a kids have been through it. And so,
um, you know, that was again another
product line and that Ed Solutions is
another department, if you will, inside
of Ramsey today and pretty substantial
revenues for high school, college, and
even middle school, uh, curriculum.
And and then, uh, you know, corporate
America says, "Okay, we'd like for our
employees to get this stuff." So, we
take a modified version of the Financial
Peace University that doesn't have as
much of the Bible stuff in it.
Yeah.
Um, and we have to not violate, um,
some HR rules and stuff. So, we had to
change some of them, make it a little
more of an L on different things. And,
uh, it's called Smart Dollar. And, gosh,
man, lots hun- I don't know, 10,000
companies have now taught it including
big ones like U-Haul and, uh,
uh, Costco. All of their employees have
gone through it. So, that's a whole
'nother product line, but it's, you
know, there So, there's the brand suite
or the product suite continues to
evolve, uh, as we look at different
things where we can serve. Uh, we took
over all the publishing and so, we do
all our books now. Uh, self-published
have for about a decade.
How do you think about spinning out new
products? Like what to do versus not
like because there's obviously focus in
a business, right? You have limited time
and resources. Like how do you say this
is going to be something we're going to
just partner with someone on or this is
something you something we're going to
bring in house and actually own entirely
or just not do it all and ignore and
just let somebody make some extra cash
on it and we just don't worry about it.
Yeah, um,
well, one thing we don't do is we don't,
um, we have made a conscious
philosophical decision to not sell
financial products. So, we don't sell
insurance, we don't sell investments,
um, we don't sell real estate. We
endorse people that do.
Mhm.
But, they don't work for us. They're
advertisers of sorts, endorse- you know,
our, uh, Ramsey trusted is what it falls
under that brand. So, some of them are
have ads on the podcast, some of them we
say, "Go to the website and fill out a
form and find the realtor we recommend
in your area that's Ramsey trusted."
That kind of thing. And so, that way,
when I'm giving real estate advice,
someone doesn't say, "Oh, he's just
trying to get us to do that." Now, they
still say,
"He's trying to just get us to be a real
estate lead." But, that's a different
than he's trying to sell me a house, or
he's trying to sell me a mutual fund. We
don't endorse particular mutual funds.
Uh and we don't um sell investments like
that. So, you can't say the reason Dave
does insurance is because or says term
by term insurance is because he owns a
term insurance firm, cuz I don't. And
you know, one of the lies out there
floating around is I own half of
Churchill Mortgage, which I don't own a
dime of. It'd have been nice if I had,
and I'd have done really well. And I
don't and I don't own half or some of uh
Zander Insurance. They're both
advertisers, been with me 26, 27 years
consecutively. And um but, I don't own
any of those. They're just They're
They're They're friends of mine, but
I've been doing business with them for
three decades, and they do really well.
And they do a great job for our
listener.
And so, those are media partnerships.
So, they're sponsors, and that's how you
contact them.
That's all they are. I mean, they're
just advertisers on the on the original
talk radio show, which is now
like you guys. I mean, you know,
podcasting, YouTubes, and TikToks, and
the whole thing. Everything. Yeah.
What have been some of the major
beliefs that you had to break along the
journey from And if So, what's what's
top line revenue today across all of the
portfolio? I'm I'm calling it portfolio,
I'm using my own language, but across
Ramsey Solutions.
Ramsey Solutions uh revs will be a
little over 300 million this year.
Okay. So, for context in terms of size
here for my audience, 300, a lot.
So, what what What were some of the cuz,
you know, a lot of businesses grow, at
least in my observation of businesses,
is they're they're stepwise. It's
they'll they'll grow, they'll grow, and
they'll hit something, and then they
stay there until they figure out
whatever that thing was, and then they
go super fast again, and then they hit
another wall, and they keep going. What
have been some of the, you know, two or
three major pivot points in the business
in terms of your lessons or beliefs that
you had to reshape that allowed you to
break through to new levels of growth.
You know, I think because the product
line was so
diverse,
um the
different ones of those were stepping at
different times
Mhm.
and it caused our actual revenue growth
to not stair-step, but to be fairly
smooth
Interesting.
on a curve.
Got it.
Um but like, you know, if it we went for
instance to Financial Peace University,
it went through different seasons where
it would go wee and then it would stop
and it would just sit, you know, and and
we're kind of in one of those stop and
sit modes now cuz we're making this
transition uh from being primarily
church distributed
Okay.
uh cuz churches aren't teaching classes
like that in this current environment as
much as they used to.
Yeah.
And so we've got to have a more
direct-to-consumer uh digital uh
distribution methodology and we're we're
discovering that right now. So it's
plateaued right now.
Got it.
Financial Peace University is awesome.
It's excellent. But it's but from a
business revenue perspective, business
model, it's, you know, it's big spike
would have been in the mid-2000s.
Okay.
I mean, it made woo, it went crazy up.
And it was kind of like the 800-lb
gorilla revenue-wise inside the
building. And then it moved over to the
other thing. So uh
what are your question was not the
stair-step question, your question was
uh what are some milestones along the
way?
Like lessons, beliefs that you had to
shift that allowed you to be an
entrepreneur that could get to, I mean,
10 I mean, do you remember when you hit
your first $10 million year, your first
30, and your first 100, and your first,
you know, any any big changes that
happened in you as a person that
that you can denote and say, "I learned
this and this is why we were able to
break through that."
Yeah, I I figured out um
fairly early
that
um that organizations are not going to
outgrow
the character and uh intellectual
capacity
of their leadership.
Uh primarily me.
And so if I'm if I remain dumb in some
of the areas I'm dumb in, then we're
we're not going to be at 600 million,
you know, I've got to
or somebody else will be doing it and if
they remain dumb, they can't you just
can't do it. I mean, there's stuff you
don't know and so I was a I grew up in a
real estate household. Mom and daddy
were in the real estate and real estate
business and so I've been selling my
whole life straight commission for me
but self-employment is a
I isn't my DNA. I don't I don't know how
to think about working for someone.
Uh and so I'm and when you would grow up
in that world, you know, you learn to
kill it and drag it home cuz you ain't
got anything to eat if you don't kill
something and drag it home and so
um very tactical.
Mhm.
And so I couldn't spell strategic
when we started. And we got large enough
that we started hiring these things
called MBAs and these people that
actually had and now over the years I
got a ton of MBAs on the team and I love
the MBA programs, most of them that are
out there. They do a really good job of
teaching but one of the things I learn
almost universally about MBAs, they are
heavily steeped in strategic thought.
Mhm.
And so um
the MBAs on our team and me about 20
years ago made a really good trade.
Um they taught me how to think
strategically cuz I didn't know how and
I taught them how to work.
So it was a good trade.
And so would you say that basically them
coming in and talking strategy was like
a big unlock in terms of growth?
critical thinking skills. I the way you
solve a business problem. How do you you
know, I would just go in there and go,
"Okay, the answer is activity. Just go
run into the wall enough times and the
wall will fall down." Meanwhile, the
MBA's standing over the side going, "Hey
Dave, over here there's a tour. If you
just walk around, you really I mean, you
don't have to run into the stupid wall.
This is dumb." And so
cuz they're they're looking down on the
maze, the labyrinth and can see the way
through and I'm just going just get
after it. Just get in there and hustle,
you know, and you need to have both. You
got to have the energy of the hustle and
grind and the cuz when in doubt activity
is the answer, but
unfocused, unplanned activity is not
always fun. It causes pain sometimes,
too. So, we're much better at uh
what my friend Jim Collins calls
calibrated cannonballs now than just
firing cannonballs.
Would you
From a branding perspective, because I
think you've developed a really strong
brand,
what are what are some of the deliberate
decisions you've had to make to
associate with versus not associating
with
in order to continue to strengthen the
brand, expand the media, because I would
imagine like in the flywheel that is
Ramsey Solutions, the media is a huge
part of that. And so like what has been
one of the big things that kept that
wheel spinning and expanding compared to
the many other people who try to to top
you. I mean, even the people who try and
get more audience, more eyeballs.
Yeah.
I uh
I don't know. We discovered I don't know
how we figured it out. It was
accidental. I guess it was people
getting pissed at us in the early days.
We you know, like we would endorse
something on the radio.
Mhm.
Just local te- local radio station and
you know, go to such and such a car lot.
Well, somebody go over there and think,
"Oh, the guy tried to screw me, Dave."
He'd call me up on the air or call me up
at my house, you know, find me in the
mall. You know, "You The guy you sent me
to is a dadgum crook, Ramsey. And so now
I can't trust you."
Yeah.
And
um
and I would lose the advertiser cuz I
would have to cancel them cuz I was
ashamed
Yeah.
of them. And so, somewhere along the
doing stupid stuff like not vetting who
we're going to associate our brand with,
instead just buying it just Oh, we were
so happy we had an ad sold, you know, we
made a little revenue, my God. And then
you figure out, "Hey, that that doesn't
play well cuz you're destroying your
credibility with the market." We figured
out we were a trust brand.
And uh radio endorsement taught us to be
trustworthy.
Worthy of trust. And uh so, we're very
careful. Uh as a matter of fact, just a
few minutes ago I came out of a meeting
where I turned down two potential
advertisers and sales team said, "We
think we need to turn these down, but
before we do it, it's a lot of money. We
need to ask you." And I said, "Yeah,
that
that guy, if we put that guy on, he's
going to that's going to cause our
audience is not No, that's not okay. So,
would you send your sister there? Would
you send your mom there? Would you send
your friend that you play softball with?
You know, would you send them over
there? And if they don't pass that acid
test, we don't put them on the air. So,
if I won't really buy it or I don't
really believe someone should buy it for
their own good, um
I mean, like 100% of the things we
advertise, I don't necessarily buy
personally at my stage of life, but I'm
not the market for them either. So, um
uh but but I do believe in them and I
believe they're good for you. And um
sometimes we mess that up. We've
endorsed things we shouldn't have
endorsed in the early days. Even I mean,
it's it's
uh in in the last few years, I've had a
really disastrous one that was a mess
and it's caused me all kinds of
problems. But, um
you know, initially started out good and
then turned bad and we didn't we didn't
cut them off fast enough. Uh and it's
our fault for not cutting them off, but
we weren't doing it for money. We were
we're trying to help people. And so,
it's a trust brand. And so, no single
relationship, advertiser, endorsement is
uh
it could not possibly give you enough
revenue in our world
Yeah.
to offset the damage it will do if they
don't take care of the customer.
Yeah.
Because people all we've got is trust.
And if they don't trust us for that,
they also aren't going to trust us when
we tell them to get out of debt. They
also not going to trust us when we tell
them, "Hey, this is going to affect your
marriage." You know, the the advice we
give is no longer trustworthy if the
endorsement is not trustworthy. So, the
whole stinking thing ends up revolving
around this word. And so, we spend a lot
of time
discussing and vetting and
cheesecloth in the whole it's a mess.
But yeah, it's it's okay. It's worth the
effort.
I agree.
I'm with you on that. And I mean, I
think that you know, at Equity Mates
Network we've tried to do the the same
kind of approach which is like how can
we be as trustworthy as humanly possible
because you know, we we do equity deals
and so we have a huge vetting process
and you know, 99.999%
of the the audience I have will never do
business with me.
Um but
I still need to treat you know, everyone
so that the reputation which compounds
is based on trust so that we can do
deals over the long term.
and just to be very
transparent, it um
it's emotional for me and most people in
this building
when that doesn't go right. When we mess
that up somehow because we our intent is
to never mess that up. And when it gets
messed up, it hurts our feelings more
than it does anybody's.
My mentor of mine gave me this quote,
you might like it. He said never risk
the empire for a pot of gold.
There it is. That's a great one. I love
it.
So
speaking of pots of gold. So 300 million
is where you're at right now. What do
you see as the as the next thing to get
you know, Ramsey Solutions to 600
million? Like you were saying earlier.
Like what's the what's the path forward
there? Like what do you see as the
strategic opportunity? What are you
investing in right now?
Um
well
we're seeing an explosion with our
EveryDollar app for one thing. It's um
it uh
with minimal effort honestly has caught
fire. So we're going to pour a little
more gas on that while we're at it.
We're going to put some effort into it
since it's working. And we do think that
Financial Peace University is going to
stair step again. We've got to finish
we've got to find that
um methodology for delivering those
age-old principles in a new in a new
way. We are platform and delivery
agnostic. I don't care how we get it to
you, but we got to get it to you. And
it's not inefficiently with the least
friction possible so people actually do
the stuff. And so, that that's there. Um
Uh some things are going are
logistically have um
in the last, say, 20 of the 30 years
have be not They didn't shrink, they
grew, but they don't have the logistical
ability to grow uh revenue-wise as much.
An An example of that would be live
events.
Mhm.
There's only so much of that you can do.
And it doesn't it doesn't hockey stick.
Right.
You you cuz you you have a bottleneck of
actual bodies on a stage. Yeah. And
bodies to set the stage up and that kind
of stuff. And number of cities you can
actually draw a crowd in and that kind
of thing. So, um the only way you could
hockey stick that thing would be to run
the prices where they were just not for
the average guy. And our whole thing we
do is for the average guy. So,
um so, that's going to if they if it
stays the same or grows at 5% and
something else grew at 50%, it's going
to get to be a smaller and smaller piece
of the pie
Right.
mathematically.
Yeah.
Uh but not still not be something we're
ashamed of. We love live events and I'm
we're one of the biggest event companies
in America. We do a great live events.
But, um but it's going to end up that
one's not probably going to be the
answer. Um unless not streaming, yeah,
could. Um
It would have to monetize for the first
time.
Mhm.
They suck on monetization. But, uh but
it's good at getting information out
there. Uh so, I
uh um
I we don't see hardcover books as being
something that's going to hockey stick
in the coming years. But, I do think
they're going to continue to be a a
valid part of the mix.
Um so, it's probably more
digital application and delivery because
it's the easiest to scale and lowest
cost of goods.
And um
and it uh more easily iterates than
anything analog.
And uh the rate of change
uh exponentially
increased in 30 years.
Mhm.
It used What What used to would take us
5 years to see unfold in the marketplace
is unfolding in 5 or 10 weeks right now.
Yeah.
And um
how fast entire social media platforms
become irrelevant
Mhm.
is is kind of amazing.
And so, you know, betting the whole
thing on one delivery mechanism, woo,
dumb. And so, um
uh
in my mind anyway. But, yeah, so so
I think it whatever it is is going to
like an app, like a budgeting app, or a
delivery digitally of FPU, or delivery
digitally of our Entre Leadership, which
is our small business
teaching and coaching,
you can only have so many
physical coaches for small business
guys.
Right.
And that's got a limiting factor. Do I
want 3,000 of those people in a
building? No, I really don't.
Yeah.
I'd lot rather figure out another way to
help you folk out there and that that is
um
not as manpower hungry.
So, when you said the Every Dollar app
just kind of like took off, is that like
a micro example of how product iteration
works for you? It's like, let's throw
something together, let's see how it
works, and then if it starts taking off
disproportionately to like the effort,
you say, "Okay, now we're going to
invest more resources in it."
Yeah, we put a huge amount of effort
into building it and launching the
initial.
It was a major initiative and a push.
And then it kind of
you know, it it was had a good growth
rate, but it really wasn't But,
something shifted in the marketplace, I
mean
literally in the last 4 or 5 months.
Okay.
And the way the consumer is viscerally
responding to the word budget
Mhm.
differently than they were certainly 10
years ago, but probably even 10 months
ago. And so, when we developed things,
so we're going to you know, we've always
iterated it, we've always updated it,
we've always made it better every time
and all that kind of stuff, but um
there just seems to be a some
attention that we didn't cause.
So, why not join the parade?
Yeah, right.
I think probably some of that's the the
macroeconomic environment has changed a
little bit in the last, you know, in
that period of time. People are probably
feeling the need for a budget.
And it might be that I mean I think the
product the the original launch on it
was uh
it's probably coming up on 10 years, you
know, so
Okay.
and the um
you know, the
the number of people that are walking
around adults
that have have uh never lived in a world
that wasn't a smartphone world
Mhm.
is much larger than it was 10 years ago.
Yeah.
And so the marketplace has shifted in
that regard with the the
the iPhone, the uh
um
whatever whatever smartphone is native
to a much larger percentage of
population than it was
uh when it was launched. So, we may just
be seeing that demographic shift and
that um
They're aging into it.
Yeah, that because they you know, that
age group, I mean, if you're 28, you you
wouldn't ever think of doing a budget on
paper.
Right.
It would not occur to you that that no
more than you would handwrite a letter
in cursive. You know, I mean, it's just
absurd. So, but you know, when I started
all this, that wasn't neither one of
those was that unusual. Right.
So, speaking of of
of the app in particular as as a an
increasingly large part of the pie.
Mhm.
Um how does it measure compared to the
other pieces? Like just by percentage,
you've got the events, you've got the
education, you've got entreleadership,
uh you've got the app, you've got the
live events. Um like how how do how do
how do those divide up in terms of
uh like size for Ramsey Solutions?
The Ramsey trusted items which includes
national advertisers and uh the whole uh
SmartVestor Pros, all the endorse all
the people we endorse for um investing,
all the real estate agents, all those
there's about 8,000, 9,000 different
people that we endorse for in different
areas, tax, all that tax and
real estate and investing
through Ramsey trusted. And then you've
got a singular national advertiser like
a Churchill Mortgage for mortgages. That
kind of thing. All that falls under
Ramsey trusted. So that's a lot under
there, but
the the
the national
associations plus the strategic
alliances we call them the the what used
to be called the ELP program,
probably amounts to 40% of the revenue.
Really?
And so
not
let it not putting on back to our
earlier conversation, not putting on one
that's bad
Yeah.
is a big deal there because you're going
to mess up the whole thing, you know,
you're going to mess up the empire with
that singular bad pot of gold. And so we
have to, you know, to be a real estate
agent in Ramsey trusted, you really are
really going to do the stuff we tell you
to do or we're really not going to let
you in there. I mean, it's a big deal,
you know, and so cuz we love you and we
love our customers and we want everybody
to have a little love fest. We don't
need anybody pissed off. So you're
really going to do this stuff. So that's
probably
I think it's probably sitting at about
40% of the revs right now. But that's
half that I've gone building too in
terms of the 1,100 people that work
here.
Entre Leadership is probably
15%
uh
you know, something like that. Financial
Peace University is probably
15%
Every Dollar is
10% maybe or less. It's less than 10%.
Um
but they you know, they just kind of
fall out like that. Publishing and live
events together not that huge of
revenue, but again, they're almost
They're like middle of the funnel
almost. Yeah, they're almost lead
gathering things. So um
I'm trying to think what else falls in
that P&L, but just something like that.
Those are the big ones.
Yeah, those big rocks.
How do you think about reallocating or
reinvesting capital within the business
versus taking it out of the business
as an owner?
Mhm.
Well, we we uh
don't randomly if we have something we
can
I can get more ROI
here
on something that we have a high belief
in than I could anywhere else.
Mhm.
I mean, certainly on mutual funds or
real estate.
Right.
I mean, I love mutual funds or real
estate, but I mean, I get a thousand
percent ROI on launching a product.
Yeah.
And I can't even approach that on this
other stuff. So,
uh I would rather deploy the capital
here, uh but I don't need to deploy it
stupidly. So,
Mhm.
um
when in doubt, uh we take it home. And
When in doubt, take it out.
Yeah, yeah, that's it. And and plug it
into the you know, plug it into
generosity and plug it into some more
real estate or mutual funds.
So,
um I'm going to I'm going to pivot a
little bit on the on the investing side
because I wanted to give you a something
that you might not know, but you did a
um a podcast with Graham Stephan, and he
was
fun. He's a great guy.
Yeah. Graham's Graham's a nice guy.
He's done He's done a great job, too, on
his stuff, man.
Yeah. He's following in your footsteps
in a lot of ways.
He's Well, he he's he's different, but I
mean, he's doing He's good. He's We like
him.
Yeah. Graham's a good dude. And he
showed you his investment
uh portfolio.
Oh, yeah. That's like a thing he does
when he has people on. I'm like, I don't
know, Graham. I don't know if I'm
qualified to help you with that, but
yeah.
You said something to him that massively
changed the direction of how we
invested, just so you know.
Yeah.
So, I I just wanted to share that with
you. So,
I think you had said loosely,
"Well, before I look at this, if this
were your brain or your knowledge or
your experiences, what percentage of
this pie would you say is real estate
versus stocks versus anything else?" And
he said, "Well,
I mean, cuz he'd asked you, "Do you
think I'm over indexed on real estate?"
But when you asked him the question, he
said, "Well, I mean, I guess probably
85% of my knowledge is around real
estate." And I think his portfolio kind
of reflected that. You're like, "Well,
then that's a perfect mix for you."
And for me, as we were coming out of the
of our liquidity event, we'd probably
taken about 40 million home before that.
Wow. Good for you. That's awesome.
Not 300.
It was 300 gross, dude.
I know.
You know the difference in gross and
net?
Um but anyways, we
and so I had during while I was growing
the business, I I basically just didn't
really invest at all. I mean, I just put
it in indexes and was like, "I'll deal
with it later." Um and then we had the
liquidity event and
I had I talked to probably every guy
that I know was who was richer than me
and was like, "What should I do with all
this?"
And the answers that I got were as
different as there are people under the
sun.
Yep.
Which left me more confused than
anything. And so, the reason that that
little piece of advice that you gave to
Graham was so meaningful for me was that
it was personalized. Because everybody
told me what they did.
Mhm.
And what had worked for them. But, you
know, the one of the guys I asked was
like, "Oh, take all that and buy one
huge building." And I was like, "I don't
know anything about I was like I really
I don't want to risk everything on one
building." He's like, "Well, I've been
doing this 30 years. Like, that's what
you should do." I was like, "But,
I'm going to mess this up."
That scares the crap out of me.
Yeah, it's all Yeah, I have no idea I
have tenants and termites and toilets
and all that stuff. I have no idea how
any of that stuff works, right?
And so, when I thought back on when I
looked at that pie and thought, "Okay,
well, what's my knowledge space?" It was
like, it's all business. Everything I've
done has been business and all the money
I've made has been business.
And so, um I showed that clip to Layla,
my wife, and I was like, "I think I
think this is what we should do. I think
we should just stick to business and
just buy businesses and grow them."
Ooh, I love it. I love it.
That's what we did with acquisition.com
is that we're
Ah, good for you. That's a great Wow.
But, that little piece of advice changed
the direction of how I mean, how we
allocate all of our assets and what we
do because it's funny cuz what if I was
going to write a $5 million check into a
building, I I did I got like, you know,
three or four deals that were around
that size in terms of check size. And um
I'd get all the way to the end and I was
like, I don't know what I'm doing.
And I'm just trusting that this is a
good deal. Like I I had the Excel sheet
and the, you know, projected returns and
all that stuff and I was like, I don't
feel good about this cuz I don't know.
When on the flip side, if I'm going to
write a $5 million check into a
business,
I feel fine about it because I'm like,
oh, I know how like I know I
I don't know everything obviously.
No, but I mean, it's your it's your
sandbox.
Right. And so um anyways,
That's beautiful. I love that. That's
What what happened was we had a product
that we called
wealth coach for a little while.
And uh we ended up doing these very
small, but I don't know, we charged more
than we ever charged, like a thousand
bucks or something. We always charged 20
bucks so to come to this little
seminars. And we would end up talking to
these people that were millionaires or 5
million or 10 million. And I I kept
asking them, okay, what do you put money
into?
Cuz they're they've actually done it.
They had money. Like you've actually
done it. You had money. And so it's not
someone with a theory on TikTok, you
know? And so um
what I kept hearing from them was this
array of all kinds of different things.
So I couldn't It wasn't The answer to
the question wasn't a certain investment
made them rich. What it was was they put
money in stuff they knew.
Yeah.
And I mean, one guy was a car dealer and
he had a massive classic car collection,
which for
ego-driven person is a horrible idea.
Right.
But because because you can lose your
butt in in any kind of collectible. But
for somebody that is in the car business
and his his grandfather had a dealership
and he his father had a dealership and
he had a he he knows that, loves it. He
goes out in the garage and pets the
cars. I mean, you know, so you guess
what? He's making that portfolio
seriously
gave him a great return. Now, do I
recommend to the general public go get a
car? No.
No, put money in stuff you understand
and you love. And don't put money in
stuff because it sounds fancy.
Or somebody, you know, it sounds
sophisticated cuz there's something
happens when you get money. You think
that everybody that has money is
sophisticated about their investing. And
what I figured out was almost no one is.
Yeah.
They're very primitive. I mean, a lot of
people I talked to were farmers and you
know what they got? Lots of land. They
got dirt, man. That's it. Just dirt. And
it don't even I mean, they don't even
necessarily plant it, but they just buy
dirt. And one guy had 8,000 acres of
dirt, you know, and I'm like, God, in
Kansas, you know, and I'm like, golly. I
wouldn't even cuz I don't know anything
about that kind of dirt. I like real
estate, but that would scare me to
death. Yeah. But it for him, it was the
most comfortable natural thing in the
world to your point. And so, I just
learned that put money in stuff you love
and you understand. Don't put money in
stuff because it sounds sophisticated
cuz you're getting ready to lose your
butt cuz you're trusting some guy who
doesn't have any money who's trying to
sell you something. And
driving a
well, a bad car. And so, yeah.
I won't name the bad car, but anyway,
I mean, that's that's where that came
from. It was just anecdotally
hanging out with those folks and
researching it and it gave me peace
because I was starting to make bank for
the first time and I'm like, I need to
be like doing double backflip limited
family partnerships or some kind of
crap. I don't even know what they are,
but I probably ought to be doing one if
I'm making this kind of money and and
then I and you talk to a guy and he's
like, yeah, you ought to do a double
backflip with a twist. And I'm like,
yeah, but get right up to it and I'm
going, you know, I don't half under No,
I think I'd rather just bury it in the
backyard than that cuz at least I know
where it is, you know?
It's funny though because even with the
dirt example, there was a guy who his
entire investment strategy explained in
an interview. He's like, you guys are
going to be bored about what we're going
to do for the next 55 minutes cuz I can
explain it in five. And we're like and I
you know I'm listening I'm like okay
here it you know here's it he said okay
so what I do is I find a city
and I find the main street cuz usually
there's a a main street that goes
through the middle of the state the
oldest street whatever. He's like and
then I take a ruler and I go out 30
miles. He's like and then I buy all that
land. He's like and then I wait 20
YEARS.
I LOVE THIS GUY.
AND WHAT ARE THE WHAT ARE THE big
He's like so what do you want to do with
the rest of our time together?
They're like so how do you hedge He's
like oh
I buy it in cash cuz you can't you know
can't take loans on land and yeah that's
that's what I do and we've been doing
that for many many many many
I had dinner with a guy the other night
that had two billion dollar net worth
and he's second gen but his dad was dirt
doing dirt
Mhm.
not unlike what your friend was doing
and um then he couldn't get the bank to
do the deal he was borrowing money to do
the dirt
and so he bought the bank.
It was a little hometown bank and they
screwed with him and so he bought it.
And he's like okay now they'll behave
and um
then he started making money on the bank
and got in and got to figure out how
bank and and now they own like 15 or
20,000 acres three wineries around the
world and a whole bunch of banks.
Bunch of community banks and they and
they're billion multi-billionaires and
so yeah but it started from that and
they don't really do anything else is
the wineries are more of a fun project I
don't I think they know what they're
doing with those probably the way he was
talking.
He knew wine and
the
uh but the
but he knows banks and he knows dirt.
And that's where all their money is.
Yeah. And they're not diversified for
having as much billions
with an S you know I mean it's it's
interesting. Those kind of people are
enthralling to me.
And it's interesting cuz most of of the
billionaires that I have looked at, they
usually make their money in one or two
vehicles that they know exceedingly well
where they feel like they have an unfair
advantage and like they they they get
there not because there's a marketplace
advantage, but because they have an
information advantage. They know it
better.
Exactly. Exactly. And
if you go through the Forbes 400, I
think it's 67% last time I looked are
first gen.
Mhm.
They're all billionaires now. You don't
qualify if you don't have a B.
And um they're first gen and I think
I looked at them
uh of the first gens
uh
it was 90-something percent were
business driven.
Mhm.
So, it was Michael Dell,
you know, Bill Gates,
Mhm.
um Hobby Lobby, David Green, um
Chick-fil-A, Truett Cathy, um you know,
and so they started a business and it
led to either they took it public or
they just monetized the crap out of it
and it just has a value marketplace
valuation. Oprah,
Yeah.
you know, um
but you know, the the secret of Oprah's
wealth is not her celebrity status. It's
the empire she built under the celebrity
status.
And so, um you know, you go down those
things like that and you go, "Okay,
you can get to 1 to 5 million dollar net
worth with your 401k and your paid off
home.
Yeah.
Um but you you know, mathematically
impossible to get to a billion in your
401k. It's not possible to do it.
Yeah.
So, you got to do there's other
strategies to be involved if you're
going to do that.
So, I wanted to take a quick second
because uh it would it'd be hard for me
to to to talk to Dave Ramsey without
talking about debt. And um
a lot of people So, in my audience, um
I'm kind of debt agnostic. I don't talk
much about it. Um but a lot of people
don't know that I actually have no debt
either. And so, everything I've bought
to this point in my life has been cash.
Now, I'm not against debt. I just
kind of like talk about uh
you know, when I get right at the edge
of something, I just I end up not doing
it. Um it's been that way with most kind
of loan things in general. And I read uh
financial or Total Money Makeover
um
years ago. And you had this line in
there about debt that was I'm going to
try and say it back to you as I
understood it because there's there's
obviously the big biblical component,
but for everyone who might not believe
in that um
I wanted to give at least my rat my
rational understanding of how you see
it, which is that debt introduces risk.
Mhm.
And risk when it when compounded over a
long enough time horizon, no matter how
big a number you acquire, any number
multiplied by zero is still zero.
And so if you know that you're going to
be playing this game for a very long
time, even a small amount of risk when
you're going 200 miles an hour can flip
the car.
Mhm.
That was my understanding of how you saw
debt.
Mhm.
Is that accurate? That's That's how I I
saw it or at least I interpreted your
view on debt.
No, that line is actually from Warren
Buffett. Um
he in one of his his famous annual
reports, they're they're very cheeky and
fun to read and especially the opening
paragraphs or so. In one of those, he
was talking about in a down year like
'08, um you know, we soon discover that
leverage is not always your friend. And
those of us that could do math realize
that any number multiplied by zero is
going to equal zero.
Yeah.
And that does that for you. So yeah,
it's um again, having grown up in the
real estate business, one thing you're
going to do in the real estate business
when I was growing up, if you said I'm
going to be a real estate investor, they
took you to the hospital, they took out
your risk meter, and they broke it with
a hammer. And they put it back in.
You're not allowed to perceive risk if
you're going to be a real estate guy cuz
cuz it's every it's glass half full.
We're eternal optimists. Everything's
going to work out cuz real estate's
always awesome. It's just awesomeness on
parade. You can't mess this up. The
renters will pay your rent. Oh god, that
I'll pay your mortgage. You how can you
mess this up? And you know, so if if a
little bit of leverage is is good, then
a lot of leverage is amazing. And uh
that's how I went broke.
Yeah.
You know, I I leveraged up to my
eyeballs on had a bunch of short-term
notes and the bank called did the
unthinkable and called my notes when
they got sold to another bank and they
saw a 26-year-old kid owed him a million
two on a 90-day notes doing flips. This
was before Chip and Joanna told us how
to do it. And so
and do a flip. Oh my god. And we didn't
have HGTV channel to tell us how to fix
up a house. I without cable TV I did
this stuff. And so
um
Yeah, so that's where it came from. And
then what happened to me because I lost
everything following the
borrow all you can because it works plan
um I had to stop
and go I think I've got a bad set of
rules.
The playbook I've got sucks. I keep
losing.
And and my
kids are getting skinny. I mean, this is
not working. So when I did that, the
first as you said, the first door I went
through was I was uh just become a
Christian and so I started studying the
Bible. And so from as a matter of faith,
I started reading scriptures. And all
the scriptures say negative things about
that. It doesn't say it's a sin. It
doesn't say you're going to hell, but
it's stuff like the borrower's slave to
the lender, you're a fool if you cosign.
I mean, it says these things in
scripture. And then you talk to old rich
people and they go, "Well, you stay out
of that, boy." You know, and okay,
that's kind of grandma God's and
grandma's ways of doing it. So, what did
I miss in academia when I fell in love
with leverage?
Mhm.
From an academic viewpoint, because how
is it it's incongruent to me that if
this book of wisdom
and these people that are long in the
tooth with gray hair
that have proof, social proof, they've
got money and they kept it
are all saying avoid debt. What is it
that we're missing in academic land with
my intellect? So, spiritual, social
proof Now I got to solve it
intellectually. And what I ended up
doing, I ended up speaking at uh
Vanderbilt to a group of MBAs early in
my career and it it it forced me to cuz
I knew I was going to go in there and
get tackled, right?
You're primitive You believe the
Bible. You know, you don't know anything
and you don't know how to how to do
math. And I know I know how to do math.
As a matter of fact, it's about all I
know how to do. I'm a math guy. So, what
I figured out was
was that in business debt
or real estate debt, uh business is not
publicly traded.
Mhm.
Um
no one
includes all the math.
Mhm.
They leave out a risk factor associated
with that mathematically. And so, we
look at a very inaccurate and primitive
measure of leverage. And so, if I can
borrow this money at 2% and I can invest
it at 8
uh why am I not making six? Well, A, you
left out inflation. B, you left out
taxes. But aside from that,
um
and that's pretty basic cuz this is the
argument. It's that it is that the
argument is that primitive.
Right.
But you did not adjust for the risk you
took on. Cuz I think we can all agree if
you have a business that's doing $10
million top line and you've got uh $12
million in debt, you have a lot more
risk than if you had $2 million in debt.
And even $2 million is more risk than if
you had zero debt. We can agree that
debt is equal to risk.
Mhm.
And if we can agree to that, then we
ought to be able to assign if we're
going to really get down in the
analytical jungle
uh we can assign a mathematical formula
to that. Well, ta-da, there is one. It
already exists. We just never applied it
in that. In the investment world, they
teach us to adjust. You don't compare an
aggressive growth stock mutual fund that
has a high peaks and valleys on the
graph volatile
Mhm.
with a growth and income fund which has
almost no peaks and valleys. So, a
growth and income fund may have a beta
of a point eight, meaning it is only 80%
as risky as the S&P.
When you're comparing it to
an aggressive growth stock mutual fund
that might have a 2.0, meaning it's
twice as volatile, risky.
And so, in that world we're taught
I mean, one of the first things you
learn doing financial analysis in that
world is the bet you use the beta as an
inverse in the math and you and you flip
it on its head and you multiply it
through and you adjust for risk
mathematically so that you can then say
after you adjust for the volatility, the
point eight versus the 2.0 versus the
S&P as a 1.0 which is your baseline,
when you adjust for that risk
uh
the perceived return of the aggressive
growth stock mutual fund at 20% rate of
return where the other one's making 11.2
it goes away. It neutralizes it. And you
might end up with with
risk adjusted, that 11.2 will come up
and the 20% will come down risk adjusted
and then you can actually compare apples
to apples, but you've risk adjusted for
the volatility and mathematically. We
don't do that in business.
Right.
We just go, "Oh, I want to buy a
bulldozer. Let's go get 50,000 at the
bank and I think I can do it. I think we
can push some dirt and that that is your
risk analysis. Well, kiss my butt. That
is dumb, okay? And and people do that
all the time and so, what I determined
was is that I'm going to go
if you want to compare two dry cleaners
you know, one has debt, one doesn't,
I've got to risk adjust for that
mathematically and you have to apply a
beta formula to that. I presented that
to this group of MBAs and they're all
sitting there with their jaws on their
lap going, uh no one ever said that and
I said it's cuz it's never been said. No
one no one does it in the world. No one
does No, you're not trained this way.
You're trained that way in only one
bucket of finance. All the other buckets
of finance, zero real estate people do
this.
Zero.
None.
They do not analyze risk. And so, if you
take risk out, then unlimited leverage
right is logical. But if you say
unlimited leverage, they go, "Oh, oh,
not quite. Maybe 80%. Maybe a 70%. Maybe
a LTV, right?" And uh you know, we But
if you push them up to the edge, they
can actually feel it a little bit cuz
they there's a remnant of a risk meter
in there, but it just doesn't function
anymore.
That's where that came from.
Oh, I love it.
Probably more than you wanted, but yeah.
No, no, I I wanted to to kind of hear
your take on it. And uh
cuz obviously, you know, in the in the
business acquisition world, there's also
debt that's that's factored in. Now,
we've done all all cash deals um
up to this point. Um but I wanted to
just kind of hear your take on it. Uh
and I I quote Warren Buffett a lot. He's
a big
Yeah. But even even in the public traded
realm, you know, if you we were taught
and and still taught
bonds are debt.
Mhm.
And so, if you're looking at a com-
company with publicly traded stock, it
has a heavy bond weight,
Yeah.
you discount the P to E. You you don't
compare that stock apples to apples with
a company has no bond rate. Zero bonds.
They have zero debt. They don't have
bank debt. They don't have short-term
debt. They're sitting over there debt
free.
You you would give them some benefit on
their stock analysis mathematically.
We're taught to do that. But again, it
does not transfer from the mutual fund
world or the publicly traded world
to the real estate world or the
small business world.
Small business uh privately held
business. These guys don't even I mean,
I know people that do you know, do have
billion-dollar top line. And honestly,
they don't even look at They just they
just some of them a lot of them just
don't borrow money. They don't even know
why they don't borrow money. They just
don't borrow money cuz somebody told
them to one time and they go, "I like
not being in debt. I can sleep better."
And that's their entire analysis.
You know? Uh me, I've got analysis and I
can do the country boy thing, too, and
say, "I just sleep
Me, I've got analysis and I can do the
country boy thing, too, and say I just
sleep better. Bring on a pandemic. I got
cash.
Yeah.
I
I'll I'll I'll I'll bring us home cuz I
had a and I could talk to you all day.
Um and I appreciate you taking the time
to to, you know, talk to me and the
audience to game up you guys. It's fun.
Fun conversation. If you had advice that
you could and I'll I'll keep it specific
to business advice um that you could
give 40-year-old Dave,
what would you tell him
then that like you know now that you
didn't know then?
Play incremental long ball. Don't look
for the home run.
Um
I keep waiting for somebody to call me
and for this to get easy.
One phone call and it's all over. And
it's like, "Oh, now I don't have to
think about it anymore. Someone else is
going to do it for me. It's all
automatic." It's never going to be
automatic. It's never going to be easy.
It's um
It's a hustle and grind. It's a claw.
You're going to make a bazillion
mistakes.
Make mistakes that are experiments that
you survive. You put out a hypothesis.
You survive the experiment to
live another day to have another
experiment. Put out another hypothesis,
another product that fails, another idea
that fails. And our failures at Ramsey
are
in new in number and in money are way
greater than our successes. The only
thing is we survive them. A, we didn't
have debt and B, we never bet the farm
on one horse. And so, from a
diversification standpoint, we never
pushed all the chips to the middle of
the table on one hand. And so, we're not
looking for the singular home run. Uh
we're looking to survive and fight
another day and keep iterating. And the
the
culmination of that uh the accumulated
value of those iterations are what we
call the gleaming mountain of success,
which turns out as a pile of
our community is a 100 gold 100 golden
BBs, no silver bullets.
There you go. That's the one. That's
exactly you You know, you beat me to you
That's much better than mine. I would
have would have just gone with that, you
know. It's the same thing. I keep
waiting on the phone call, but I mean,
it's never I had a couple of my thought
was it, and then
I was um found out they were just
people, and they weren't magic.
What's funny cuz I joke with our
community cuz a lot of my community is
small business owners, you know,
probably, you know,
from $100,000 a year to $100 million a
year is probably like the the broad
brushstroke of the people who are
listening to this. Um
and the biggest thing a lot of them
suffer from is, you know, shiny object
syndrome. Is that
as soon as something starts to get hard,
something new looks easy. And so, they
jump from the hard thing to the easy
thing, and really it's just uninformed
optimism. And then they get into it, and
then they have informed pessimism.
That's beautiful. That's beautiful.
Yeah, I mean, by the time it shines,
you're late.
You're late. It's too late.
I mean, if you think TikTok is new,
you're late.
Yeah.
It's already not new.
It may have already turned down and we
while we were talking right now.
Well, I I mean, if if if we have a
second, let me know. Um in terms of how
cuz you've survived A survived is a
strong word. Uh you've thrived uh
platform agnostic. You know, you have
you I mean, you were in radio, you've
done live stuff, but then I see YouTube
clips
uh of your show pumping out every day.
You guys crush it on YouTube, and you do
it kind of your way. Um how have you
thought about navigating
platforms as they come and go, and how
you kind of like reinvest in what Where
Where are we going to make a bet and
say, "Okay, we're going to start
expending resources here." Or is it just
if there's attention, we'll go there.
Like how how do you think through that?
Uh we try to go there, and then we
expend resources based on um
results.
And so um
the YouTube shorts that we've been
pumping out is only about a year and a
half old.
And uh we're getting incredible results.
Yeah.
Uh
but we're getting results on those as an
example. Um
we don't view those as life
transformation items.
Okay.
We view them as lead magnets.
Mhm.
To lead you to the long-form show to
Financial Peace University to a book
which are life transformation items. So
um they're um
free advertisements that cause people to
get a get a little sample. You you get a
little little old lady standing at
Costco with a sample biscuit, right?
Okay.
And so you get a little sample. And um
uh
you get a little sample biscuit and then
you may go buy the whole thing in the
freezer. Uh and but so we
I would not do In other words, our
philosophy on like changing lives is why
we're here. We would not only do YouTube
shorts because they don't change lives.
Mhm.
Okay. We would not only do uh the new
long-form TikTok, 6 minutes, 7 minutes.
We would not only do that. Uh cuz it
won't change life.
Um and so it's got to lead us somewhere
and based on its response on doing that
or just general activity around whatever
the item is, whether it's a long-form or
short-form. Uh it it is we're going to
we're going to pour gas on where we're
seeing stuff work. And you know, so we
don't you know, for the last 2 years we
put uh
little to no effort in growing Twitter.
Mhm.
Um
Tucker Carlson might change that.
It may become a broadcast medium.
Mhm.
And um
so we'll probably be on Twitter next
week.
Well, Elon's definitely pushing it.
and he's going to but I mean, they're if
it's not going to just be a uh a
cauldron for trolls uh then um and it's
actually going to put out some positive
information uh in a way that is
consumable and could grow and talk if if
Elon proves that with Tucker, I mean
we'll jump in there and try it right
now. And all that is we're not going to
put a ton of money on it or
uh resources or bandwidth on it, but
we're I this week we were discussing
we're probably going to try it and talk
what Tucker's doing and what Elon's
doing with Tucker and with that whole
idea of broadcasting there. Um because
Facebook live is didn't work. I mean
it's not working.
No, not even on
Um not from our perspective anyway. But
we're still there. We're not we didn't
abandon it, but we're not putting effort
on it. Where YouTube shorts, yeah, we
have a lot of people in this building
working on that every day, yeah.
You guys crank those.
Yeah, they do. They put out a bunch of
them.
When you think about content for you,
are you cuz you're recording 12 hours a
week, correct? 4 days, 3 hours a day.
Oh, 15 hours, okay.
Well, counting commercials, yeah. We do
we do 3-hour talk radio show every day.
And is that the entirety of your kind of
content creation and then the teams take
all of that and disseminate it through
all the the the channels?
Uh
I do a podcast that I just took over
that's caller driven on leadership and
small business called Entre Leadership.
Took that over in January. That and the
Ramsey show are the only two things I'm
on.
Mhm.
But Ramsey Network has about 10 shows
that are YouTube and or radio and or
I mean we put them on everything, but um
I mean the Ken Coleman show is the only
one that's on talk radio, 75 stations
plus podcast plus YouTube. Um Delony at
John Dr. John Delony has a huge show on
podcast and YouTube only. Uh the Rachel
Cruze with George Kamel, the Smart Money
Happy Hour. And but we sawdust every one
of those.
Every one of those can
say sawdust?
Uh we're going to take uh pieces and
clips and do all kinds of things with
them. Instead of we don't go create uh
well, I say very seldom do we go create
a YouTube short of anyone in the
building or anything in the building. It
is
clipped from something we were already
doing. Mhm. So, it's repurposed
uh content that was already developed
for something else.
You know, highly edited.
Yeah. I I mean cuz I've
I've observed what you're doing and
thinking like how can how can we do even
more of that kind of stuff?
Lots of payroll.
Payroll. Yeah. We're Our media is
Um all right. Well, uh
this has been phenomenal and uh I'm
honestly just so grateful that uh they
they had me and my team out here um to
uh this is considered Ramsey Solutions?
Is that what this would
Yeah, they're we'd call it that.
Ramsey Solutions
studios, yeah.
Um and uh just also so grateful for that
one tiny tidbit that
Wow, wow. I'm honored I had a tiny bit
to do with
all that you do, man. You're amazing.
I'm proud proud of you. Well done.
Means a lot. I appreciate it. Well,
thanks so much for having coming on the
game. And hopefully
we'll do something in the
You can count on it.